the other day I saw this tree that I
made for my boyfriend like a year ago
for our anniversary and I thought god
this is ugly so I asked him hey should
we throw this away
sure and in that moment it felt like a
slap and place and I did a complete 180
Hey
that was a trick question and you failed
this has our dreams on it huh get
married
build a family found a kitty farm and
you just want to you just want to throw
our dreams in the trash it was a hundred
percent my fault because I'm the one who
said should we throw this away and I'm
the one who thought god this is ugly but
it was like being 13 again where you
call people hang up on them and then
call them back to ask why did you hang
up on me
I didn't you're lying we all ask loaded
questions does this dress make me look
we should just rephrase these questions
entirely amazing so yeah I'm kind of
working on you know being more self
aware and being less full of shit
Oh Riley rewind is coming out in three
days December 12 we actually did a deal
with Facebook so for the first 24 hours
Riley is gonna be on Facebook and then
after that we are putting it on Ray's
channel on YouTube and other thing so um
I hope you like it it's been a very long
process but I learned a lot and
ultimately I'm proud of it and yeah
Linna
stay awesome Gotham no kiss no no kiss
Oh